if we're closing out let's talk Farley
for a few minutes right so I met him his
brothers were on this show it was the
worst ranked show in history he was like
ranked 130 out of 131. I'm doing a scene
and people are starting to really laugh
and I turn and Farley law is is there
he's in a suit and he goes he goes how
are you all right how are you good to
see you good all right and I go I have
to do something that he'll remember me
but I I just half this is my hero and I
go hey everybody
look it's the big fat guy taking all the
attention away from the skinny Punk
who's trying to have a career and he go
looks at me and goes that's it and he
runs over he picks me up over his
shoulder starts smacking my ass we go in
the golf cart afterwards up through
Universal the psycho house we have beers
I go back to his house to have some
drinks